les enfants et le sport si le sport à
l'école n'est pas entrer vraiment dans
les moeurs en france l'a fait vrai il ya
encore beaucoup de progrès à faire cela
n'empêche pas les enfants des mais le
sport et de le pratiquer de plus en plus
tôt alors c'est une bonne chose une
mauvaise chose en tout cas la télévision
a sûrement joué un rôle important dans
la pratique du sport pour les enfants ce
n'est pas un hasard si les parents
souhaitent que leur rejeton pratiquer la
gymnastique ou le tennis qui sont des
sport éminemment télégénique et si les
enfants pratiquent de plus en plus
jeunes est ce une bonne chose alors nous
allons en parler dans un instant avec le
docteur jolibois qui est pédiatre qui
est avec nous qui répondra à toutes les
questions qu'on peut se poser à ce
propos mais d'abord regardez ce
reportage de bruno l'adresse à toulon
emilie c'est la petite dernière elle
s'accroche mais l'exercice est un peu
difficile pour elle
dans ce club de toulon la gymnastique
commence presque au berceau disons au
biberon puisque dès 3 ans ben basât
bambine font connaissance avec divers
appareils
on commence avec la poutre pas facile
j'ai vu ça
moi je le fais le doigt dans la bouche
et moi tout seul
plus difficile encore la barque
même chloé deux ans et demi a voulu
essayer
peut mieux faire
conseils de leur faire prendre
conscience de leur schéma corporel de
l'espace et du temps par différents
exercices de gymnastique et des sceaux
démarche l'expérience lorsqu'elle a été
lancée il ya huit ans et est unique en
france elle a vite séduit les parents et
plus rapidement encore les enfants moi
je fais aussi la gymnastique sportive et
je me suis dit qu'après tomassi pourrait
très bien enfin comme moi
ça lui plaît autant comme moi elle ne
nous en parlent à la maison sur le
papier ça nous a refait un exercice
qu'elle fait ici à gymnastique oh oui sa
lutte et c'est très très variés alors ça
m'intéresse beaucoup
des années de travail pour réussir à la
perfection un tel exercice
peut-être parmi ces tout jeunes enfants
trouvent at on plus tard des champions
actuellement nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de recul pour dire bon
thème championne est issu de sur vos
plats mais par contre nous avons déjà
quelques enfants qui sont passés dans
des groupes supérieur et dont nous
pouvons nous apercevoir les nets progrès
par rapport aux enfants qui n'ont jamais
pratiqué à c'est à cet âge là
et lui reste-t-il de mcenroe
à trois ans on peut également commencé
le tennis
premier contact premier exercice faire
tenir la balle sur la raquette
pas encore de matches et il faut d'abord
apprendre à taper dans la balle
on leur apprend faire le un jeu de
jambes l équilibre l'adresse une
coordination
ont fait du pratiquement des jeux de
balle les jeux de ballons et un peu plus
car on prend la raquette pour les
initiés est-ce que six jeunes on repère
déjà ce qu'ils pourront avoir de qualité
de bons joueurs on arrive à dix les
disons qu'en prison un entraînement un
peu plus poursuivis et n'arrive en faire
des petits champions
0,8
pour les champions pas de problème reste
à former les futurs arbitres
cette fois ci